thank you for attending today's webinar
amino serology treponema screening
advantages of using over sequence
algorithm I'm Lance linker at the DSR
product manager for infectious disease
product line before I introduce our
speaker for today dr. Tiffany Mackenzie
just a couple of brief housekeeping
notes in the lower left hand corner of
the speaker page you will find a CEI con
after today's presentation is complete
you will be able to click that icon to
register for your C eat credits also
there will be time for questions and
answers at the end of the presentation
if you have any questions there is a
question chat box that you can submit
your question that dr. Mackenzie will
answer these questions at the end of the
presentation it is now my pleasure to
introduce our speaker speaker for today
dr. Tiffany Mackenzie dr. Mackenzie is a
scientific affairs manager for dia Soren
focusing on infectious disease gk media
strong with more than 10 years of
laboratory experience she started her
academic career at the University of
wisconsin-madison studying molecular
biology and received her PhD in
pharmacology at the university of
minnesota-twin cities before coming to
DIA Soren dr. Mackenzie spent three
years in research and development at
access genetics LLC in Eden Prairie
Minnesota developing HST multiplex PCR
assays please welcome dr. Tiffany
Mackenzie thank you very much Lance for
that kind introduction and it is my
pleasure to walk you through today
immunoassay serology atripla me moans
screaming assays that are available on
the US market and especially the
advantages of using a reverse sequence
algorithm and will go into great detail
as to what that means and Aslan said at
the end please submit your questions via
the chat box and you know please take
note of any questions you might have the
whole presentation should take about 40
minutes so we'll have plenty of time for
questions and we'll be live until 1pm
centered central time so I hope that by
the end of this presentation today
you'll take home with you a few key
learning objectives specifically being
able to describe three methods or you
know a few of the
methods available for diagnosing
syphilis infection so both from like a
historical standpoint and also just
understanding some of the different
chemistry's and technologies that are
available and then also comparing and
contrasting the two algorithms that are
used in the diagnosis of syphilis and
and also understanding how those weave
in and how those fit in with clinical
guidelines specifically CDC or Center
for Disease Control guidelines and also
be able to at the end of today name
three benefits of a treponema specific
igg IGM a say in identification in in
really for screening for syphilis okay
so a syphilis has been long known to
humankind some of the first cases
reported in medical literature in the
15th century and it was a particularly
bad disease to have before 1928 which is
because probably prior to that point um
is this was prior to the discovery of
penicillin and so the ongoing sort of
you know one of the phrases affiliated
with syphilis is one night with Venus
and a lifetime with mercury meaning that
so before the advent of penicillin
mercury was the only treatment available
and as you can imagine the side effects
were almost as detrimental or toxic as
potentially having syphilis itself but
in any case shown here I really like the
TV show is serious bones and so I'll be
able to detail medical cases from the
skeleton is interesting so here you can
see the 18th century English skeleton
showing advanced syphilis because the T
pallidum can invade the bones in
tertiary syphilis and so just keeping in
mind that this is long known to affect
human kind but yet it is still prevalent
in our society today in the US and
worldwide and so we here I'll come back
i'll revisit this schematic later in the
talk as well but i just wanted to
introduce you
just so that we're on the same page as
to just the general phases of syphilis
and then what are some of the hallmark
symptoms affiliated with each stage so
assuming the beginning of the arrow or
the beginning of the timeline is point
of exposure to the bacteria at T podem
so the first be at this primary phase in
the first like so within 10 to 90 days
of exposure is when the patient may
first present with a chancre to their
physician these are her physician and
then and so the primary phase of primary
phase of syphilis roughly runs this
course and I'll go into more detail as
to the timing of each phase and when I
go into the serology of antibody
response to discipline but in any case
and then a patient would progress
assuming no treatment or you know no
intervention took place at the patient
wouldn't would progress into the
secondary phase in the hallmark symptom
for that is this rash that presents on
the palms and the feet and so this can
occur anywhere from like six weeks to
six months post exposure and then after
that point still assuming no
intervention which you know could have
happened a long time ago it still could
happen today there were a couple case
studies at a the CDC STD Congress that a
couple of us from the assarn attended in
Atlanta last week that there was a case
study at in Madison with a patient with
tertiary syphilis where the Tiepolo Tom
had invaded his one of his bones in and
it was reporting knee pain so again
still happened today in any case you
progress to this asymptomatic phase so
this can persist for decades and then
eventually and also the cdc groups
neurosyphilis in this in this category
and then and then finally the tertiary
syphilis is
when the tipo de may invade some of the
major organs of the body causing you
know such as liver cardio cardiovascular
system and a number of other bones so it
could left untreated it could have very
detrimental consequences so of course we
want to intervene so um and that
underscores the point of so okay just
how prevalent or how many cases are
reported per year so this is pulled off
the cdc of physician self-training i am
not a physician I'm a scientist but I I
still go to this website regularly for
as a resource to understand the clinical
picture of syphilis in the u.s. today
and so you can see here that there's
like an all-time low let's say of
syphilis cases in the early 2000s but it
is very slowly increasing and also it
was obvious at the CDC STD conference
that we went to a couple weeks ago that
there are outbreaks and especially MSM
and we have sex with men populations
throughout the country and so definitely
syphilis surveillance is a hot topic
especially for public health concerns
and centers and so you can see that it's
the number of cases in thousand so
looking at the whole country and then of
course the prevalence or the incidence
excuse me does vary state-by-state
geographically as well and so for
instance if you picked out Kansas you
would see ya point eight divided by a
hundred thousand we're looking at it
incidence of about point zero one four
percent and so and so generally speaking
the incidence is a little higher in the
south and a little bit lower and some
other states at least what's reported
but you can see that looking at special
populations so for instance msn
populations and pregnant women
populations you can see that in pregnant
women the prevalence is even lower so
this is a previously we're looking at
say ten to fourteen out of a hundred
thousand this is you know one or two out
of a hundred thousand so this really
underscores the point that we need you
know whenever you're designing any kind
of a say you want the sensitivity and
specificity to be as high as possible
and sometimes you have to sacrifice one
of the other depending on what you need
to prioritize for the essay but in this
case for pregnant women you really want
the specificity to be perfect I mean
really good because the prevalence is
even lower than just looking at the u.s.
population in general and of course we
want the sensitivity to be there as well
which is enhanced by if you're looking
for like let's say G and M specific
antibodies together versus G alone but
we will get to that in a moment so um I
guess you can think of terpening mole
excuse me syphilis tests can be sort of
divided into three different categories
one would be if a patient presents with
the chancre or a rash and you want to
investigate the specific lesion how can
you visualize it how can you say
concretely that this is being caused by
T puddin and one way to do that would be
dark field microscopy has been a
historical way but if any of us know who
have worked in the lab long term you
know any kind of microscopic technique
and here shown here is fluorescent
microscopy but any kind of my crust
microscopic technique is not amenable to
screening or you know high-throughput
reference laboratory any any sort of
situation like that so again it is it is
beautiful for you know getting an idea
of you know what the organism what the
spire Keith looks like but also it's
important to note too that in contrast
to let's say chlamydia gonorrhea teeth
palladam cannot be cultured either so
this is also posed sort of a diagnostic
challenge in terms of monitoring
syphilis medically speaking um and let's
see here
okay so and then so what like I was
saying the so as syphilis tests can be
divided into three different camps so
yes like looking let's say taking a swab
from the chancre itself like a
site-directed investigational test which
may be today perhaps molecular testing
will start to play in that field and
then there's also two different camps of
tests so there's um trip anemal tests
and an entrepreneurial tests so trip
anemal tests including fluorescent
turpin email antibody testing adsorbed
to an on podium trippin trippin team
this is more of a historical essay but
more currently looking at T political
idiom hematocrit nation antibody this is
the acronym used in Europe here we use
DPP a format agglutination antibody
tests which have largely replaced
fluorescent testing but even more recent
so we'd be looking at eliza base
chemistry so or EIA enzyme-linked
immunosorbent assay also we could look
at Western blot again if you're going to
look at the specific antigen maybe more
for a research purpose but again western
blot is not really amenable to
high-throughput screening but the most
current or you know state-of-the-art
technology is a chemiluminescent
immunoassay technology which is a sort
of an evolution of Eliza technologies
and I'll go into a little bit more
detail later too about how how it
differs and then so these are some of
the trip any mold tests available and
the key distinction between these two
camps is that trepanning will test
specifically detect antibodies to t
polygamy whereas non to prenatal tests
detect nonspecific ana antibodies to it
and to the cardia life in antigen which
is released from the trip name itself
are also other life in antibodies
released from damaged host
and so these tests include the venereal
disease research laboratory test in the
rapid plasma reagent test and these
tests are still you know used today for
monitoring active syphilis infection in
response to treatment and so just to
underscore that the CDC STD treatment
guidelines state that the use of only
one type of serological tests is
insufficient for the diagnosis of
syphilis so I don't want you to walk
away today thinking you can only choose
one or the other you if one of them is
negative and it's you know up to each
lab which kind of use but then you could
report out a negative result but if you
want to confirm an active syphilis
infection you have to use a test from
each of those each of those camps or
each of those types so I mentioned that
I would get into this a little bit
earlier so here is a sort of a plot of
the Syria logical response of a patient
exposed to t polygamy so you can see
here that so the solid lines represent
the T pallidum specific antibody
response and where's the dashed lines
refer to or representing the nonspecific
at anti lipid response that a test like
our PR would detect so you can see
primary syphilis so generally speaking
is categorized within that first month
of exposure or more specifically let's
say the first three weeks and from 10 to
90 days is when that primary shanker may
present itself at the site of infection
but in any case so two weeks post
exposures when the patient when a
patient would exhibit a trip specific
IgM response and this antibody titer is
going to wane over time or decrease over
time whereas the trip specific igg it
will present itself about a month post
exposure so a little bit delayed after
the M of course but once a patient has
been exposed to t pallidum they are
paused he or she is positive for life so
that's an important note to make and
then the dashed lines you can see
for so our PR VDRL they are detecting GM
antibodies to anti-car do lifan so the M
would be detectable five weeks post
exposure and the G would be detectable
six weeks post exposure and these
antibody titers will also decrease over
time I mean the the g4 anti cardiolipin
may be positive depending on the patient
for many many years but just keep in
mind that you know if you want an answer
have as a patient ever been exposed to t
pallidum the way to determine that is
through a trip specific igg ok so now
revisiting that schematic that we had up
earlier um sort of grouping stages of
infection with hallmark symptoms now
let's start looking at what how is the
performance of the non trip renewal test
and the trip anemal test at each of
these stages and so this is a
publication or a book from 1990 so it's
a little while ago so but I does the
same concept still applies looking at so
VDRL are PR are looking at they are the
nun representing the nonspecific non
trip animal tests available and then fta
or tpha are the trip any more tests
available so today well today it's still
our PR is largely used for monitoring
infection live active infection but
largely today that's like tpha let's say
would be replaced by eliza or CLIA
chemistry but in any case so at this
primary phase because of that delay in
the anti cardio life in response the non
trip animal tests are going to detect
active syphilis infection only 75
percent of the time but the trip animo
specific tests would be ninety percent
of the time or at least according to the
results from this study and then once
you progress into the secondary or
asymptomatic or let's say secondary
phase of syphilis that's when all of
those antibodies are definitely high so
either either test non trip anymore or
trapani
should detect with very high accuracy
high sensitivity high specificity at the
secondary phase however once you move
into this asymptomatic phase or the
tertiary phase you can see that the non
tripping emo tests start to only detect
the active infection three-quarters of
the time whereas the the trip any most
specific tests will be positive one
hundred percent of the time so this is
because the g is positive for life but
one thing to note would be yeah so this
really depends on yeah so this is
assuming a non-treated patient because
if a patient were treated and there are
PR went down four fold then this would
drop off so this is untreated patients
so just giving you an idea of the
performance of non trip animal
interpreting will tests at each stage of
syphilis and then also just revisiting
this idea that you know of course the
phyllis has long afflicted humankind and
so getting into a little bit of culture
here but you can see that this bust from
musee de rome in paris showing a patient
with tertiary syphilis and these goo
mattes or gummy tumors is another
potential symptom and then other
tertiary effects again could lead to
damage internal organs like brain heart
liver bones eyes and nerves so it's it
is pretty amazing that although this has
been present in our society for you know
many centuries that it is still
prevalent today are still present today
and so speaking to that so what does the
CDC say about screening for you know for
pregnant women specifically so syphilis
screening is recommended by the CDC and
essential to prevent congenital
transmission and shown here is a public
health poster from the 1930s just so
again this is long been a public health
concern
and so the CDC does specifically
recommend pregnant women screened be
screened and counseled at least at that
first prenatal visit and just a little
bit more detail the risk of transmission
to the fetus is highest during primary
or secondary syphilis but infection may
occur during any trimester and only
severe cases are clinically apparent at
birth so it is really important to disc
reen the expecting mother just because
because it is asymptomatic in the infant
at birth okay so we are convinced that
we you know we do need to be screening
obviously I'm not getting into MSM
populations as much or you know other
public health testing centers but taking
pregnant women as an example population
it is apparent that we you know it is in
order to be following clinical
guidelines we do need to be screening
pregnant women so the question is then
we have all these different tests
available as specifically the
non-traditional or the non troppo animal
interpreting will tests how do we how do
we perform these tests that's the main
question and so to quote sort of a read
up on this I pulled an article from the
journal of clinical microbiology where
two physicians were comparing the
performance of the traditional or the
reverse algorithm in their individual
laboratories so the the physician
practicing the traditional algorithm
which by definition is the first
screening with an entrepreneurial test
followed by a trip animal test the
physician performing that was a
physician at Mayo Clinic in Rochester
Minnesota and then physician advocating
the reverse algorithm was a physician at
University of Texas who was using the
bio-rad trip animal immunoassay screen
and then following by a non tripping emo
test so um okay so i will get into this
in a little bit later with the exact cdc
guidelines but i just wanted to
introduce this concept to you and and
just to also brush you up our you know
bring us all to the same page as to what
the replica plasma reagent sa does so it
is still even though you know it is
perhaps not amenable for a large
reference lab to do in you know with
large throughput screening there have
been cases where you know laboratory
medical technologists are you know
starting to be affected by carpal tunnel
and other organic sort of issues with
this repetitive testing and so although
might not be amenable to that it is
still definitely useful in terms of
monitoring active infection so you can
see here that and it is subject to
interpretation a bit but on here on the
upper left would be a reactive well and
then and then it is important that over
time so one of the posters we were
looking at at the CDC conference that
this is important for monitoring active
infection and you can see you should see
a four-fold or so dilution in a response
to penicillin treatment and then over
time the patient so it should see revert
cyril revert to a negative serology are
negative result okay so that's just an
idea of how something like our PR works
and now a cartoon on how a
chemiluminescent chemistry works in
general I mean this is specific to our
essay but you know any other
manufacturers may have a similar design
but I'll just speak to our
say so this is a one step a say it's the
most simple one we have actually and so
in in this format we have paramagnetic
beads that are coated with the tpn 17's
antigen a recombinant antigen and so the
key difference between one of the key
differences between Clea
chemiluminescent technology and Eliza
technology is that with these beads so
if you imagine this line is actually I
should maybe redraw this but it is
actually a complete sphere so it's
you're optimizing the surface area
within your reaction module and so as
opposed to being limited to only the
bottom of an Eliza plate well so you're
going from two dimension to three
dimensions so that is one of the
advantages of chemiluminescent
technology in general and so this perrin
magnetic bead is coated with the tpn
17's recombinant antigen and then
assuming that a patient is positive for
syphilis and let's say in the secondary
phase of infection and I'm positive for
both G and M so the G antibody and green
em in red then uh both of those
antibodies would have the opportunity to
bind to the recombinant antigen and then
also in the same step the tpn 17's
antigen is added which is conjugated to
a nice aluminum derivative called a bei
and so this is all allowed to incubate
and then the entire reaction so with a
magnet you attract the reaction to the
side of the module so that it doesn't
wash away but then you wash to get rid
of any nonspecific binding and then
after the addition of a couple of
starters to initiate the luminescence
you are you report out an index value
which so if it's greater than or equal
to 1 point 1 this
is determined to be positive and if the
value is between point nine and one
point one that's the equivocal zone so a
retest should be done and then if the
index value is less than point nine then
that can be termed deemed negative and
so just a little bit of background about
our da saurons chemiluminescent
treponema sa was 510 k cleared in 2006
and our predicate device that we
compared to was the Kappa you Isaac
chemistry so again chemiluminescent
chemistry utilize a chemistry you know
at least in this case they do perform
very similarly it's just the workflow
that can be really different for the
laboratory and then our essay was
cleared for screening so syphilis
screening and confirmatory use so
meaning you could use it as either the
beginning or the initial test in the
alga testing algorithm or is the
confirmatory test that you know FDA said
it's fine for either way and I just want
to point out as well that in contrast
you know I'm the scientific affairs
manager for a lot of our infectious
disease assays and so oftentimes let's
say when you're screening for measles
immunity the positive might say that
you're protected or something like that
but here the positive says you need to
supplement with an entrepreneur test you
cannot report out that the patient is
positive because it could be that they
were positive for igg underwent
treatment and no longer have an active
infection so you really have to
supplement with an entrepreneurial test
like our PR and then so getting so
revisiting now this uh the the Tiffany
mole versus the reverse algorithm so
this is kind of the key part of the talk
and so this is pulled directly from the
CDC morbidity mortality world report
from 2011 and we're all anxiously
awaiting the next one to come out so the
CDC does recommend the trip animal
screening algorithm however the reverse
algorithm does have a number of
advantages but so pulled direct
from the MMWR report the CDC says that
despite these recommendations for
reverse sequence screening the CDC
continues to recommend the traditional
algorithm with reactive non troppo
animal tests confirmed by trip anemal
testing so but that said I really I
think that more testing can be done and
is being done and there are a lot of
groups you know including public health
centers also a couple of US Army sites
are switching to the reverse algorithm
so slowly slowly more and more labs if
it makes sense for the lab is looking at
the reverse algorithm and I just also
want to note that the trip animal
algorithm has been commonplace in Europe
for over 20 years and so the assarn
where a European or more specifically an
Italian company and so a lot of our
we're always you know it's kind of a fun
part of my job to is understanding how
medicine is practiced in Europe versus
us but in any case so the CDC does still
as of this 2011 report was still
recommending the trip animo algorithm
where you start with our PR I'd say and
then confirm with a trip animo specific
tests but they do not say that you can't
do the reverse algorithm so it's up to
each individual laboratory you are still
abiding by guidelines as long as you
perform you reverse algorithm in this
format so the CDC suggest starting with
either Eliza or our chemiluminescent
chemistry so EIA is the same as Eliza or
CIA is the same as CLIA and then if
that's negative you can report out a
negative result no problem but if that's
positive then you do need to confirm
with quantitative our PR and then if
that's positive then you can be quite
certain that this is an active syphilis
infection if this is negative for some
reason which I you know it could could
be then it is good for the each
individual lab to have on hand an
additional sort of backup method so like
an agglutination assay would be a very
nice method to have on hand just to
confirm
I confirm active syphilis infection and
actually the chemiluminescence studies
that we have performed have shown that
chemiluminescence does compare quite
well to tppa okay so now for the
remainder of the talk i would like to
really dig into the data of the
performance of chemiluminescence versus
eliza versus our PR and so so this is a
review from the journal of clinical
microbiology referring to more
specifically just showing that let's say
in primary syphilis yes you can see that
the sensitivity is lower than later in
syphilis but i'll show you these data I
just wanted to pull up that these data
are referred to in a very nice review
but i'll show you the data in a easy to
read table so okay so shown here you can
see that the performance of
chemiluminescence specifically
chemiluminescence tripping team of
sensitivity is higher than our PR and
treated or untreated patients so you can
see in untreated primary syphilis our PR
sensitivity was only about 60 2.5% we're
comparing to Eliza the captal aiza our
predicate device for 510 K clearance was
about 75% whereas the liaison
chemiluminescence performance was a
hundred one hundred percent progressing
into secondary syphilis the performance
between chemiluminescence and Eliza was
really quite almost comparable at that
point but our PR is still um still quite
a bit lower at only 80 two and a half
percent so I just want to underscore the
point that our PR sensitivity is
definitely inferior to some of the newer
tripping email based technologies such
as
eliza and chemiluminescence and then
shown here is the chemiluminescent
treponema just showing that it reduces
the load of false positive results
especially in obstetrics patients and so
these set of data are nice because you
can see a head to head that the
performance of chemiluminescence is
actually very similar to the performance
of tppa so keep a lid on the particle of
illumination sa so so that's a good kind
of confirmatory result but you can see
that even in the normal group already
there's a little bit of a drop of our PR
let's say ninety seven percent versus
100 or 99 but in cases of autoimmunity
like a na positive samples the
performance of our PR is 80 the
specificity is only eighty seven point
five percent versus one hundred percent
by either tppa or chemiluminescence and
you know again this is due to the fact
that our PR is detecting cardiolipin and
this may be secreted by damaged host
tissues in response to a number of other
medical conditions not only Smith not
specifically syphilis so looking at
mononucleosis commonly induced by
epstein-barr virus and the specificity
of our PR was ninety percent versus 104
chemiluminescence or tppa lymes disease
actually that's another spirochete so
that is important in terms of thinking
about specificity that we want to make
sure that this test is looking at
syphilis that you're not looking at our
detecting borrelia burgdorferi and so it
performs well they're all three of the
essays but then in pregnancy and again
if you're looking at how to screen for
syphilis and pregnant women where the
prevalence is really low you really want
a highly specific assay and so at least
in this cohort in patients which is in
over 2500 published in 2005 you can see
the specificity of our PR was only
eighty percent versus one hundred
percent for either TPPA or or
so I think this really drives home the
point that although our PR is still you
know an excellent tool for monitoring
active infection in terms of a screen
you know it does have its limitations
because it is not as sensitive as shown
in the previous by the data in the
previous slide and it's also not as
specific as shown by the data here ok so
just wrapping up here with the last few
slides of some performance data so one
of our largest and most prestigious labs
running the liaison chemiluminescent
chemistry in the reverse algorithm
format is a kaiser berkeley in
california and they showed improved sa
performance to our PR so this is again
looking at so chemiluminescence versus
our PR is that first stage screening
test and as a couple slides ago is as we
observed so add a disregarding stage of
infection things like that I'm just
looking blindly our PR sensitivity was
seventy-three percent versus
chemiluminescent sensitivity was 100%
the positive predictive value so the
likelihood that if the patient has a
positive result that it is indeed being
caused by T pallidum that positive
predictive value was ninety-three
percent for chemiluminescence in only
seventy two percent for our PR and then
clinical specificity again was almost
one hundred percent for
chemiluminescence versus only
ninety-four percent for our PR and again
this is not surprising looking at the
previous slide with the different
medical indications that might be
causing a false positive result so and
then the negative predictive value so
the likelihood that if you get a
negative result the patient does not
have the disease that is actually very
good for both tests so so depending so
if a patient has resulted out with a
negative our PR they he or she can be
pretty confident that it is indeed
negative
assuming he or she yeah they can be
pretty confident that it is indeed
negative ok so just wrapping up here one
final comparison table so excuse me so
so one final comparison table so the
other main T playdom specific automated
sa available on the US market is via via
the bile Plex from bio-rad and so just
looking head-to-head at some comparison
dr. Lee he works at the reference
laboratory in Paris at and so he did a
comparison with 392 samples so looking
at the Syrah in an unselected format so
Clea trip animal IgG IgM shows improved
sensitivity over igg only serology so so
looking specifically a primary syphilis
because liaison detects IgG and IgM
whereas the bio red sa detects only igg
there are a few samples that would have
been missed by this algorithm because
the the bioplex are the bio red eye GMS
a is only cleared in ce marked and not
510 K cleaned for use in diagnosing
syphilis in the US and so just a little
bit more specifically on that so you can
see that the soul for these seven
patients that were in the primary
syphilis out of out of 392 of these
seven patients we're all detected as
positive by liaison and also by looking
at a number different antigens by
western blot could be confirmed positive
and looking at a combination of bioplex
G&M would have been would be positive
but looking only at the G there are a
couple patients that would have been
missed by this testing algorithm and of
course i would i would love to repeat
this with
more patients in a larger study but it
is just an important note to make and
then finally just understanding that
trip anemal the trip any more screening
albuq algorithm or the reverse algorithm
can be automated and this can reduce
labor costs and increase throughput so
so regardless of what kind of automated
instrument is used this any kind of
fully automated random access a solution
would address a number of workflow
issues especially in a large laboratory
large reference laboratory such as
manual subjectivity laboratory
information system connectivity
interruption errors and repetitive
motion injuries which again I've heard
several accounts of this being an issue
with medical technologists that have to
process a lot of our PRS so something to
keep in mind how automation can really
help with workflow and prevent the
laboratory from having to do additional
testing or be delayed and reporting out
patient results so now just we're
wrapping up one of the favorite parts of
my job is I get to facilitate
collaborations with key opinion leaders
all over the country and conduct
clinical studies so some ideas that I
think would really benefit the
literature would include comparing the
positive predictive value of treponema
to traditional testing algorithms and
select populations especially pregnant
women you might recall from one of the
slides that the positive predictive
values through between chemiluminescence
and our PR was really different the
negative predictive value not so much
but really understanding the performance
of these two essays in the positive
predictive value I think would be really
interesting and then also comparing the
false positive rates of our PR versus
treponema screening in a population with
a high prevalence of syphilis and also
looking although I'm scientist by
training but also comparing the
cost-effectiveness of tripping email to
traditional testing algorithms in
vs. let's say a smaller labs like a
point-of-care lab I think all of these
would be really interesting avenues to
pursue and then finally just revisiting
our learning objectives for today so so
three methods for diagnosing syphilis
infection so I have it actually grouped
into three bullets here so you can
that's kind of a take-home message in
itself to that so dark field microscopy
or let's say molecular testing might be
the present day way to detect like an
actual causative agent detect the
terpening T pallidum from a site like a
chancre and then another kind of camp of
syphilis tests include the non trip
animal tests of course our PR VDRL which
are detecting IgG and IgM against
cardiolipin and then trip animo test is
the last camp so including like the
agglutination ish they Eliza based
chemistry's chemiluminescence based
chemistry's and depending on the sa may
detect dior em r chemiluminescence
detects GM and i believe that
agglutination essays due to and then
comparing contrasting the two algorithms
that are used in the diagnosis of
syphilis so the traditional algorithm
may be suitable for a low volume lab and
clinic serving patients with ongoing
infection or high prevalence rates but
the sensitivity is low when you're
screening with the RP r and the method
is very very manual whereas the trip
anemal algorithm allows for automated
testing if the laboratory so chooses I
mean if it's a very low volume lab you
know definitely you could still stick
with a smaller plate or something like
that but in any case it does allow for
automated testing and enhanced
sensitivity specificity looking at the
performance of even our predicate device
capea versus our PR and it's ideal for
high-volume labs especially screening
for pregnant women with the prevalence
as well cetera
and then name three benefits of the trip
any more specific igg IGM essay and
identification and diagnosis of syphilis
so this allows you to detect primary
syphilis two weeks earlier with igg IGM
alone versus IgG IgM together versus igg
alone and then being able to detect
primary syphilis five to six weeks
earlier with a chemiluminescence than
with our PR and finally fewer false
positive positives obligating less
confirmatory testing when you're
screening with a specific T pallidum
specific test like a GM for tripping
team of vs vs a G only and I believe
this concludes our talk for today so now
we will go through the question and
answers that have been submitted through
the chat box and we have a good just
under 15 minutes to address these
questions thank you thank you dr.
Mackenzie as dr. Mackenzie said we do
have a few minutes for some questions
and answers um it does appear that we
have a couple of questions the first
question in the assay design you showed
earlier you missed it only one antigen
some antigens that are available to use
multiple antigens is there a benefit for
using only one antigen will be using
multiple antigens yes that is a okay
maybe that's not the answer to the
question but yes I understand your
question and that is a question that is
always a concern in the Diagnostics
industry in terms of sa design you know
how many antigens do you look at you
look at one do you look at a cocktail of
five you know you really have to test
each individual scenario and so in the
development of our chemiluminescent
tests at least I have right here the
development of from our product support
team at product development team and so
we did look at p 15 p 17 and also p-47
and you recall from the little cartoon
that I went through earlier that we
chose only the
p17 and that is because it is the most
reactive antigen for antibodies to t
paladin and from testing in the
development of this product it did not
you know looking at the cocktail of the
3p 15 17 and 47 verses 17 alone it did
not you know the the trio did not offer
any added sensitivity or specificity and
actually risked kind of the philosophy
in general is that the more you know the
more antigens that you look at you have
to always wave maybe you are getting a
little bit better sensitivity but then
the more antigens you look at the more
likely you are to decrease your
specificity so and then also in the
performance of our essay we were
comparing to a Western excuse me Eliza
based chemistry from Germany at the time
because this was developed in Europe and
of both assays were looking at 174
samples and each one only misdiagnosed
one sample a different sample so each
each product so you know the performance
was equipped equivalent between looking
at p7000 and vs p15 1747 together so
that's why in the development of our
essay we went with just the one antigen
but excellent question our next question
are there any molecular tests that are
available for syphilis would they be a
better option for screening so yes this
is also a question I've been asked by
pathologists practicing I was out in
Washington and the Washington Department
of Health and some other regional core
labs there and yes something also me for
me from a molecular background I'm also
curious where the molecular testing fits
in the picture with diagnosing for
syphilis so um and then in response to
that there is a key opinion leader at
University of Washington Sheila dr.
Sheila L a blue Kart so I pulled a
couple for very nice publications from
the late 90s early 2000s
her group has established you know a
very nice molecular test that can detect
down to one trippin team you know in a
sample and she also looked quite a bit
at cerebral spinal fluid and so the so
yes there are molecular tests available
and for doing something like being able
to investigate a specific lesion a
specific shanker if you want to be able
to do a swab and be able to result out
is this specific Legion being caused by
the trippity pallidum I think you know
that could be a really exciting area for
molecular testing to play but for
screening I still you know molecular
testing I it is not at least as of right
now I do not see the evidence that it's
going to replace a theological screening
I was also speaking with the doctor
khalil got him from md PhD from Johns
Hopkins at the CDC conference and it
just doesn't look like there's the
studies are there yet showing the so the
amount of tripping teams that are
positive and in the Sierra as compared
to you know IgG IgM response so I mean
it may be available as a confirmatory
test but in terms of screening you know
again once a patient is positive for T
pallidum that G is positive for life and
then you know that M is positive right
away so you really have the sensitivity
and specificity right there but
definitely in terms of replacing dark
field microscopy and fluorescence
detection of T pallidum for a specific
shanker I think that could be an
excellent place for molecular testing to
play a role it'll be exciting to see if
some of those come on the market and
become 510 k cleared in the in the near
future okay there is one more question
there are a number of rapid syphilis
tests that are becoming available do you
think these would have a utility in the
clinical laboratory um that is also an
excellent testing yeah so at this CDC
STD conference we were at a couple
weeks ago definitely in the in the third
world so speaking kind of from more
about Bill and Melinda Gates Public
Health sort of perspective rapid testing
is an excellent option just if it's
impossible for you know midwives in Peru
to be able to gather serum samples and
keep them cold and transport them across
the country rapid testing yeah for
syphilis or HIV is really exciting and
is really great to see that but in the
u.s. also i came across a poster at this
conference so looking at it was actually
looking at populations where syphilis
was highly prevalent and they were still
arguing for the reverse algorithm
advantages of the reverse algorithm so
screening with a trip anemal specific
test i believe they were using an Eliza
and then confirming with something like
our PR and this group was was saying
that that perhaps a way to confirm
immediately because so if a patient is
positive for G and you want to determine
if that positivity is due to a past
infection or a current infection and you
get a let's say you get a positive our
PR these rapid tests oats let's say you
get a negative our PR these rapid tests
would be a great way to just immediately
confirm or deny that testing algorithm
so actually the rapid test in this case
would would possibly replace the are PR
but so again i don't i'm not one hundred
percent convinced we'd have to do some
cost cost effectiveness studies to show
if you'd really want to screen with the
rapid test is because there might be a
lot of plastic and manual labor if it's
not automated on an instrument but into
in terms of confirmatory so you know
following the screen and you want to
immediately you know these rapid tests
are they're made for point-of-care
testing but i think they could have a
clinical utility in some of the larger
labs as well for just a quick yes or no
answer in terms of confirmation but in a
lower volume than the than the screening
so yes I think it could be playing
Roland
I think more and more are becoming 510 k
cleared if I am not mistaken so okay I
think that's it for our questions once
again thank you dr. Mackenzie as a
reminder don't forget to register for
your seat credits by clicking on the CD
image in the lower left hand of the
speaker page thank you for attending
today's webinar thank you very much